now the un's nuclear Watchdog has called
for an immediate halt in attacks on
Europe's largest nuclear power plant in
Ukraine the international atomic energy
agency has warned those responsible for
shelling the zaparesia plant that
they're playing with fire Russia has
accused Ukraine of being behind the
latest attacks on the facility which is
under Russian control will retire to air
Vice Marshal Sean Bell is here with us
Sean just talk us through what's
happening right now what's the latest
that you know yeah well and yesterday
evening and this morning there were a
series of powerful explosions rocks
there's Apparition nuclear facility it's
probably worth remembering though that
the international atomic energy agency
are on the ground at the moment so we're
probably going to hear more than we
would otherwise hear because they're on
the ground
um getting nervous just by uh to remind
viewers this is one of the biggest
nuclear reactors in Europe it was seized
by the Russians in right at the start of
the war in March and whilst Russia
blames the ukrainians 4 for this
shelling buildings and equipment and
some of the periphery have been damaged
but we've been reassured by all parties
that there's no critical nuclear
security or safety issues as a result of
this latest attack which is reassuring
in a sense that why is this happening
well yeah well if we look at the switch
to the broader map this this is
strategically important to
um to Russia not least of which
um Power it used to provide is average
about power plant provided power to
Crimea when the Russians invaded in 2014
the ukrainians cut off supplies to that
but it also provides a significant
proportion of power across the whole of
Ukraine and if you recall that Russia
has been targeting Ukrainian critical
National infrastructure the last month
or so so it will not want to now you
can't destroy the nuclear facility that
would leave a nuclear Wasteland but try
they will not want it to fall into
Ukrainian hands it's a sprawling
facility as well and the Russians have
been hiding their military equipment
there and then firing out from there at
the Ukrainian forces which inevitably
provokes a response and that's been
happening for quite a while the real
question is why is it happening now and
I think part of the context for that is
the withdrawal from the Russians from
Harrison over at your side there
um the the Russians are unsure whether
the ukrainians are going to continue
their attack or pause and what looks
likely now is that whilst the donipo
river provides quite an effective
barrier for the Ukrainian forces to come
across the ukrainians have been looking
to come round to the South West here but
also all around the north
um to attack the east of of zaparita as
well and that would mean that karkovka
dam is one of the crossing points but
certainly to the east zaparita now
Russia is paranoid about Ukraine
counter-attacks and counter-offensive
they are bolstering their defenses of
the Crimea they're also bolstering their
defenses in the donbass but
um if the Ukrainian forces are
successful with some of their
counter-attacks the zaparita will become
increasingly isolated the Russian forces
there will become increasingly isolated
and the challenge there is will they
fight or withdraw we're in for some very
dangerous times ahead if they decide the
former very dangerous times around a
nuclear power plant as well let's not
forget Sean Bell thank you very much
indeed